To each of these yellow bars is ten
blocks. You see that: 1,2,3,4
5,6,7,8,9,10
so you could view it as a 10 and we have
1,2,3,4
5,6,7,8
So this is 8 tens
tens and we have three 1's right over
here.
So it is three 3
We could write it as 83 we
have
8 tens in the tenth place
and then we have a three in the ones
place
What I wanna do is subtract from this
from the 83
I wanna subtract 25
so the first thing you might want to do
is look at the ones place
I have three ones I want to subtract
5 ones and you immediately say well how
do I do that how do I subtract five
things from three
we don't know how to do
that yet
what if there was a way to take a 10
from here
and break it up and turn it into 10 ones
and so we could put those 10 ones here
and adding three ones we could have 13
well we're going to do exactly that and
then we will be able to subtract
so let's do that let's take one of these
tens here
and take one away from the tens place
so let's take this one right
over here
actually underline it first and let's
break it up
let's break it up into ten ones so
1,2,3
4,5,6
7,8,9
and 10
so took this one 10 and I broke it
up into ten ones
so I no longer have a-ten
I now have 7 tens
seven tens and how many ones do I now
have
and no longer have 3 ones. I have added 10
ones to that. So it is ten plus three
is now 13
Now it's going to be a little bit
easier to subtract
if I have 13 ones that I want to take
away five
if I take away 1,2,3,4,5
how many ones on my left with.. it is
13 -5
which is equal to you 8
13-5 = 8
that the is 8 right over here and then
we go to the tens place
we have seven tens. we're going to take
away two tens
how many are we left with now?
we are going to be left with
1,2,3,4,5
we are going to be left with 5 tens
seven tens -2 tens
is five 10's so there you have it
83 -25 is 58 and what we've just done
is we've regrouped
we took a group of 10 and we broke it up
and we turn it into 10 ones and the
reason we did that so that we could
subtract in the ones place here
so that three became the sort of having 13. we have 13 ones
and we took those 10 from the tenth place
in order to do that
and to make this really clear we could
write this a different way
We started with
83 which is eighty plus three
and we subtracted
20 and we subtracted 5 that's what's
subtracting 25 would do
In order to subtract 5 ones
from three, five is
larger than three
so instead
we took a 10 from here so the eighty
became
a seventy and we gave that ten to the
three 10 plus three
is 13 and now we were ready to subtract
now we're ready to subtract 13
-5 his 8 and seventy
-20 is fifty so we were left with 50
Plus 8
or 58